- So today I'm being turned into Storm.
- I get to become Wolverine, today.
- I'm going to be Wonder Woman.
Oh my God!
(upbeat music)
- If I'm storm, I'll be
better than any rapper
because I will literally make it rain.
Psh, come on.
- I think it's going to be
a really cool, empowering
experience to vicariously
live as a super hero.
- When I was an elementary school,
I was diagnosed with scoliosis,
which is curvature of the spine.
So then I had get spinal
fusion surgery done
in the 6th grade,
and the procedure was to get
metal fused to your spine.
It was about a year after the
first X-Men movie had come out
and so my friends started
calling me Wolverine
which was really cool transforming that
into something that made me
feel powerful and unique.
- I'm watching an episode of Wonder Woman
to get in the spirit.
- She was one of the only
female, black super heroes growing up.
It was awesome to see
someone who looked like me.
- He's so tough and he
exudes such confidence
and just badassness.
It doesn't feel very Wolverine
to be getting primped like this,
but Wolverine don't give a (beep).
- Watching Wonder Woman as a kid
made me excited for puberty.
I was like, "Maybe I'm going
to look like Wonder Woman."
That didn't happen and here we are.
(laughing)
Oh my God!
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah!
- That's so cool.
- Eee!
- Having massive claws just
make you feel like the
rules don't apply to you
- I feel like I look kickass,
but could I kick someone's ass?
Probably not because I can't
move in these heels at all.
- It makes me feel so strong
and like I could do anything,
it's also just kind of sleek and sexy.
- Being a badass was allowed,
and it's just such a cool
feeling to just be like,
"Yeah, (beep) the world,
go (beep) yourself,
I don't care what you think."
You know, it's not the nicest sentiment,
but it makes you feel cool.
(upbeat music)